okay guys okay guys it's your boy
psychobabble um we're continuing the
segment called bells town oh no you
don't need to be looking oh no all these
people trapped air and worse have seen
worse but the [ __ ] past this gate it's
all new territory to me okay I'm on it
that's shut keep quiet yeah batch I yet
okay wait I need some [ __ ] [ __ ] Cat
Cat good one and why are we supposed to
go okay I got two choices here out there
are up here
okay yeah [ __ ] a lot of cricket
noises except plant [ __ ] I China out
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] that guys
like running
okay well we got to do is take to the
left side I guess right that what is it
what is it I like get out of the way
what the [ __ ] heli get locked okay hold
up I got a key on your right is easy
what is that the [ __ ] is that
that guy got cut cut ooh sent normal Hey
look we're still alive ya SE and say
that you weren't kidding about this
place where you a lot of guys here so I
just sneak up on all them or just take
him out I walk the grass not make a
noise you know strong it to read a
[ __ ] squash a skull should they hear
that oh that's [ __ ] high now
okay I guess is nothing out here
I hear [ __ ] not see you now what the
[ __ ] is this
na schet we're gonna go up there go [ __ ]
[ __ ] chef well we claim this town out
that's just sure I cleaned it out so
we're thank ya
so much indigestion what is that now I
got a pendant okay I guess that one
wasn't hit in no I guess this house is
take a side thing check it out you guys
would give me a gun I can help you kill
some of these [ __ ] shut up shop can
we please give her a gun like I know
it's against my character but as a
person I feel like it could help and now
we're all just trying to survive here
we're all just trying to survive here
make upstairs No okay let's go let's go
are you safe taking this high road this
whole time everyone's gonna see they're
all going to see me this is really the
best place to attack
okay [ __ ] it final item oh [ __ ] I got
you up that ok turn out too well and
mostly because I did that a lot more
ammo no I thought that but I did okay
anything over here there are so many
goodies in this level chat
yes I'll take this guy out not spider
santro click this guy is so [ __ ] loud
it was saying this way oh [ __ ] it's
tired on the other side what about going
through here what the doggie door hmm
very careful of course okay maybe you
should have given her a gun ok bill
there's more are those clicker things
inside the house nah she asian he seems
yet you stay down dangle pie
come on come you up there right yeah
that klikiss come on are you going or
what what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] it they can't they're [ __ ]
devesh [ __ ] they didn't hear that i'm
[ __ ] just walking in yet another one
i ship this [ __ ] yeah the only hot my
gurgling noise I thought it would I more
ships yes she ever like the best thing
in the game did anything in here all
right oh great anything in the air what
is that over there some supplies
come on with skin up on the RVing over
should be clear shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
okay imma cheat down on after amateur up
over the RV & Co here out here the hell
love this here no although I got some
idea he might have come through here uh
wants that guy's gotta figure out I'm
gonna figure out something here oh let's
see here let's see her okay
okay we're going back it's kind of
figure out where I should end this
episode okay get inside come on really I
like trying to end it at the actual
segments so I gotta figure where it is
without spoiling it's hard to time I'm
good we're all fine let's just keep
going got la la whoever type the lives I
ok my book just do a spider central
quack a little spider science ok I like
level of something yet what's in here oh
just more cutters hello Jessica hello ok
water chuck the scouts saying is
anywhere no that's really quiet just
gives a [ __ ] in the house I want to take
out a breath in this game I know I some
[ __ ] ammo hey Joe yeah Oh chef
[ __ ] chef ok if I make something I
can't carry that
wow I can't [ __ ] him carry it [ __ ]
what is it why do you [ __ ] yell he
wants up on the ass man with this how
arrows thank you this guy's kind of a
dick why can't skip the bow and arrow to
the girl I would I tell you has that
truck sticking out of the school right
there come on Jesus there's a bunch of
them up there to make a sound can they
see us oh yeah they're visible ones
[ __ ] up
ok let's see yeah let's see there's a
game plan I could do
if you won't come in this way come on
get on the [ __ ] bus and get ready
[ __ ] oh god I'm a boxer fetch I'm a box
so you want to fight me [ __ ] yeah
nothing to hide its gonna taste my own
blood I just check out the whole plate I
then they can come up besides I can't I
can freely explore in chat
shut that [ __ ] fight them all see how
I fight them I ain't a [ __ ] I have a
[ __ ] like you [ __ ] [ __ ] hey
that's thank you yeah oh you want to
fight set [ __ ] huh all right so I'll
welcome to the pro game patch they must
be holed up somewhere well let's not
test our luck how do we get inside
forgive me up there and I'll drop to you
ok
I mean I really [ __ ] them up huh let's
go Oh indigestion it's the worst don't
get killed up there ah they put it over
there nice ass we're okay we just need
to get to the hood of the truck is that
the check that is the Chuck okay all
right ah you hear that they're coming
move it kid okay one that's a ghazal and
that's air tank so much shame Bay Rays
thank you just kidding this a little
more a chef come on I got it windows
don't put okay i guess i got in here oh
we gotta win
pocket [ __ ] sex that's not gonna hold
they'll make it fast grab this place
tell me you're done simple what [ __ ]
in Phil where to build where anywhere
from here oh come on dips out for her
Amish